anhelado y codiciado por todas las
elecciones del mundo además de la
emoción que genera el mundial uno de sus
mayores atractivos es la pieza que se
lleva el equipo ganador un trofeo que
pocos han podido tener en sus manos fue
diseñado por el escultor italiano Silvio
gatzaniga en 1971 tiene dos figuras
humanas sosteniendo la tierra que
representan tocar la gloria y tener el
mundo en las manos
cuando el diseñador Silvio gasaniga
estaba comenzando a desarrollar la forma
de expresar este icono deportivo también
estaba pensando en cómo el ganador tenía
que usarlo frente a la cámara y así fue
comenzando un camino que realmente puede
mantenerlo en las manos y elevarse como
una copa en una ceremonia esa fue una
forma de expresar el amor por el deporte
y la confianza en el deporte desde 1974
este icónico premio es entregado cada
cuatro años al monarca del mundial del
fútbol y en esta edición será levantado
en Qatar el 18 de de diciembre la firma
gde bertoni es la encargada de pulir el
trofeo de oro de 18 quilates que pesa un
poco más de 6 kilos mide 36.8
centímetros y su precio ronda entre los
250.000 y los 300.000 dólares una vez se
juega el último partido del mundial el
nombre de la selección ganadora es
inscripto en la base del trofeo y luego
entregada en la ceremonia de premiación
Posteriormente la federación de dicho
país recibe una réplica y es exhibida
ante el público mientras que la original
es retornada a la FIFA quien se encarga
de resguardarla hasta la próxima edición
cuando el trofeo regresa lo volvemos a
bañar en oro arreglamos las pequeñas
ralladuras de la malaquita y grabamos la
base con el nombre del equipo ganador
este pequeño equipo de escultores
también produce varios de los trofeos
más famosos del deporte como los de la
UEFA Champions League o la copa africana
de Naciones haciendo soñar a millones
con la victoria